I'm a former lottery winner um I a
million dollars a million
dollars yeah a million dollars on a
scratch ticket um in the state of
Virginia when I was 28 I'm
36 nice now and I have gone through it
all um for the benefit of the listeners
and a dark curiosity can you tell us
where that money went yeah so I mean
obviously I bought the ticket so I
gambled to buy the ticket right um so
that that never stopped was more so with
casinos Sports gambling Etc um quite
embarrassed by it
um you know absolutely well this is
clearly there's a addictive behavior
here have you dealt with that over the
last eight years are you still grappling
with that I've reached out to Gamblers
Anonymous um I actually have an
appointment set up